trudeau fait de bon sens choisi
radio-canada ou et de radio canada oui
jérôme l'avait depuis le déclenchement
de la campagne
il accompagne les chefs des principaux
partis dans tous leurs déplacements
d'un bout à l'autre du pays on a profité
d'un doors est commun à ottawa pour
mieux comprendre le travail des
journalistes qui suivent les caravanes
électorales seront ménagés par rapport
au travail avec le site one
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur christian noyer
nationale
ça sert à poser la bonne question au bon
moment ça sert d'être là pour
représenter les gens qui sont à la
maison on a la responsabilité nous ont
tant que journaliste de faire ressortir
les contradictions de faire ressortir
les boues épineux et de confronter les
chefs à leur programme et à leurs
déclarations
est-ce que ça va entraîner un coût
supplémentaire ou trésor canadien
et si on n'était pas là mais ça veut
dire qu'on leur donne un passe droit qui
a trait au canada peut pas se permettre
de ne pas droit à personne on est là
pour être avec eux tous les jours parler
à l'entourage
voir aussi l'entourage sentir l'ambiance
qu'on a vraiment plusieurs autres c'est
fondamental tournée des francophones
qu'on ait des journalistes francophones
qui pose des questions au chef parce que
on a des enjeux parfois qu'ils peuvent
différer pour l'audience marco von donc
c'est pour ça qu'on continue à suivre
à suivre les chefs
qu'est ce que c'est une caravane
caravane c'est en théorie plusieurs bus
qui se suivent
or un n'a pas les moyens de payer
plusieurs bus donc on partage le même
plus te donne un exemple accepter cela
c'est beaucoup de proximité et parfois
vous il n'ya même pas de porc qui nous
sépare l'ensemble des autobus alors
parfois ils se font une réunion ensemble
stratégique qui n'ont pas honte obligé
de passer à côté d'eux pour aller aux
toilettes alors l'autre les entend
chanter ou carrément arrêter de parler
et ashley et ashley journal et ça c'est
ici dans le domaine du si maintenant à
une collègue extraordinaire est-ce que
vous avez un problème de vérification de
passer de vos candidats le sujet dans
quelques heures accès aux chefs pour
vrai un pur vrai ce qui t'a très
encadrée à chaque jour par exemple moi
je travaillais avec du consommateur
chaque jour conférence de presse
15 20 minutes d'efforts plus si on étire
alors ça a été assez bien à ce niveau là
après est-ce qu'ils répondent aux
questions sont souvent une autre des
fils à nous d'essayer de développer des
stratégies entre nous mais normalement
pas mal à tous les jours ça a été un peu
moins ouverts chez les libéraux en tout
cas c'est ce que j'ai constaté jusqu'à
maintenant pas nécessairement de
disponibilité médiatique à tous les
jours ton nom de question et goûter
comment tu choisis les questions parce
que quand même ça peut avoir un impact
majeur sur ce qui retient l'attention
dans une campagne
souvent on essaie de se concerter avec
les boss haguenau patron doit on sait
que les thèmes de la journée
est ce qu'il ya un thème particulier
cette journée le 6 et le club enregistre
pose une question sur ce thème le cas
précis à l'intérieur de la caravane ya
aussi une certaine concertation qui se
fait pour s'assurer que tout le monde
puisse avoir une question sur son sujet
parce que si d'ici fin de trois
histoires glauques fait une histoire
sitv faire qu'une ou deux histoire on
veut s'assurer que tout le monde puisse
avoir sa question où son sujet quand il
ya des chefs qui vont être suivis
pendant toute la campagne
d'autres non comment cette décision la
radio canada est prise mais c'est
certain qu'on évalue tout le temps parce
que il ya la question de la couverture
des caravanes des chiffres puis à la
question aussi de la carte de la
couverture de l'ensemble la campagne
électorale
donc c'est certain que les caravanes de
chefs via des critères qui sont vraiment
objectif qu'elle est par exemple le
poids politique la représentation des
partis politiques à la chambre des
communes par exemple qui elle est quels
sont les derniers sondages au cours des
derniers mois donc on prend les
décisions fonction du poids politique tu
es parti de la 15e journée explique ça
ressemble à quoi dans la vie d'une
caravane et ça commence tôt se finit
tard pour d'or quatre heures par jour 4
5 6 6 ans une bonne nuit d'arrivée par
exemple au début que numéro neuf et
trois provinces dans une journée
mais ça c'est des journées plus de début
et de fin de campagne où est ce qu'on
veut à découvrir le plus grand
territoire possible d'avoir le plus de
monde possible
notamment ce kit de survie qui
m'intrigue beaucoup oui absolument
j'ai ma vie là-dedans je peux aller en
direct de n'importe où j'ai mon fils
trépied si jamais il arrive quelque
chose que même mon téléphone faire un
direct comme ça manquait le plus
important c'est caché ici ça c'est ma
pharmacie personnelle alors ça c'est
l'ensemble du bon journaliste contre le
mal de tête haute le mal de tête gravol
parce qu écrire dans l'autobus
ça donne mal au coeur ensuite l'équipe
islamistes on veut pas tomber malade au
milieu de la cambe haine envers savoir
ce serait bien dommage
la campagne hr qu'est ce qui te manque
le plus
la maison on voit pas beaucoup la maison
quoique aujourd'hui on est à ottawa
le dodo faire ma propre bouche ça mx1
manger froides c'est plutôt moyen et ne
pas dormir chez soi c'est la tournée des
trois étoiles
mais cela dit c'est bien mieux parce
qu'on voit le pays et là aux premières
loges quand ça se passe comme ça pète
cette eau qui poserait question chère
c'est vraiment un privilège qu'on a deux
pour vivre cette fois c'est sûr que ça
vient avec beaucoup de fans were pesant
que je n'aurais jamais pu mettre sa vie
sur pause l'espace d'un moment c'est
dans une galette c'est parfait